hey guys my name is Jess Mattel and I'm
here with your top five so I can fool
you want on five of the biggest things
that happened in gaming this week are
you still playing destiny well lots of
bits and pieces surface this week
including bugs speculation on unreleased
content and bungees comments on all that
first off a bug in the game allowed some
players to find chunks of unreleased 2
DLC content in the current game and
there have been stories from the game's
development processes coming to light
which suggests that Destiny's story a
heavily criticized feature of the game
was significantly changed towards the
end of development on the more positive
side community manager David egg
suggested a raid and weekly strike
matchmaking system may be in the works
after players continually asked for it
on the whole Bungie commented that
everyone is working to make the game
better do you have a six gigabyte
graphics card if the answer is yes you
can download an HD content pack for
middle-earth shadow of mordor digital
foundry are thrown together impressions
of the fancy ultra settings that most of
us probably won't get to experience
apparently it's not all that much of a
jump up from high settings that monolith
production says they built the game's
asset at an outrageously high fidelity
and wanted to give gamers the option to
crank up the quality
develop a Crytek upset it's getting real
hard to keep impressing gamers with
graphics the crisis and rice son of Rome
creators told dear so gaming as opposed
to the times of the original crisis we
as an industry have reached a quality
level now where it's getting
increasingly more difficult to really
wow people that said there's still
enough areas to explore and we will
definitely keep pushing the boundaries
as much as possible YouTube superstar
PewDiePie has discussed why he may be
leaving his disney-owned network and
starting his own his contract with maker
studio ends in December and he's keen to
head in a new direction from the sounds
of it saying I'm in touch with a couple
of people who I think would be so right
for this I'm eager to get it all up and
running so far all the networks have
been managed in such an incredibly cool
way it's embarrassing really I'd like to
help other youtubers make a studio who
also distributes totalbiscuit and
Yogscast was recently acquired by disney
for 500 million earlier this year with
additional performance-based pay out of
450 million I do like to end the week
with a hilarious story and here it is
well it's funny for us and not so funny
for driveclub if you thought texting
mistakes caused by your iphone
autocorrect was bad then you should
probably have a chat with sony who made
a janky misprint on the back of the
drive club game box along with
information like drive together win
together you can also find a line that
reads racing hundreds of online and
offline players now I don't want to be a
prude but that just doesn't sound right
no matter which way you spin it it's
worth mentioning this is on the official
box art so there's no turning back now
that the games out so if you have a copy
enjoy that although against what doesn't
endorse racing in players whether
they're online or offline ask your
question of the day let me know if you
reckon video game graphics can get
drastically better than they are now or
not so much
we call sides you can check out the
scariest video game enemies on the chest
we deliver you our game of the monster
September and we sure you too good the
bad and the ugly of NBA 2k15 space
scanning that is it for me this week as
always thanks for hanging out and be
sure to have yourselves a lovely you can